the Schengen Agreement removing border
controls across most of the EU is a
sacred pillar it's under intense
scrutiny now after Germany reimposed
temporary controls to manage refugee
flows followed by Austria and Slovenia
Schengen needs to be at the heart of the
EU and we need to protect him he was
speaking after a briefing from the
European Commission on what exactly the
trio's rien position of control ohs
means you can have it for g8 events you
can have it for migratory flows which
are not control and which poses some
public order issues so this is in line
with the Schengen baudot code it has to
be proportionate for some Emmy peas the
controls don't go nearly far enough
Schengen east toward the size the eyes
of a ITV it's not a moment party D&D
from sunni ethnic medic ang moh frantz
fanon for others it simply has to
function the world is on fire in our
neighborhood people are are coming to us
in order to save their lives and their
lives of their children the Commission
says Germany Austria and Slovenia have
sought an extension of border controls
until roughly the middle of October